everybody it's gary vaynerchuck on
garyvaynerchuk.com
bear with me this is going to be the
greatest garyvaynerchuk.com video ever
made actually almost made a PowerPoint
presentation and for a lot of you that
know a keynoted 30 40 conferences I've
never given a PowerPoint presentation
someone look exciting month you saw me
make it I did it with tabs in Firefox
but you know at the end of the day today
was a very interesting day so let's
recap what happened today and then let's
talk about what we learned okay here we
go
what happened today corked what's hacked
as you can see right now it's watching
Wine Library TV because I'm clever but
cork was hacked right Mott right now
next who hacked cork my adult friend
finder calm I think if you find some
pretty interesting stuff near mob that's
my year so kudos to the people there but
it was really somebody else who was
using their affiliate program to a dope
friend fiverr.com next what happened
TechCrunch which is the best what really
went really one of the only sites I go
to every day in the world TechCrunch
wrote about it good job by Robin I'm
staying on top of it so he wrote about
it people comment it so then I kind of
became aware of situation I was with all
my devs actually in here we became aware
of the situation so what happened next
was I do it you should always do in my
opinion that if something negative
happens in your world you need to
address the world you can't wait for
your PR people to come and talk a day
later you've got to be real and
authentic so what I did Mott was I left
the video using Seesmic untie rajesh
gary vaynerchuck by the way own cork
pausing that mod because i said it once
before at different conferences
TechCrunch a massively visited web site
they allow you to leave comments but
they also allow you not just capture
this right here they allow you to leave
a video comment using Seesmic okay um I
highly recommend anybody in the
marketing web 2.0 social media business
world that if you live with in the world
that has anything to do with the things
that are talking about on TechCrunch you
should be on there every single day
leaving a comment about a story because
look right there you can see MOT no
matter where somebody
is on TechCrunch I'll even go just to
show everybody why I believe in this so
much yeah we're having a good time your
mom so you know your latest comments on
your video comments did he redesign or
they off now yeah I think they might be
actually but video comments on oh there
they are
boom right on the homepage not on the
TechCrunch homepage as you're scrolling
wrong
there I am as you can see so let's say I
talked about the this widget story or
the crunchies or Google street views if
I did that every single day cited that
every day my face would get into that
community and maybe I could build a
brand if I had my own blog it's a killer
you got to do it but sorry got a little
sidetracked cuz I'm very excited we're
gonna do entire garyvaynerchuk.com about
this season make TechCrunch thing but I
figured I'd sneak it in here mine anyway
I left the video which I will link up
here to scroll down so my video right
now and there's a link to this comic so
I left the video you can see what
happened after that
Matthew underneath said best website
owner response to a hack ever honest
personal humble great stuff agreed now
what happened next month next right
after posting that kind of putting out
the fire being honest I think you'll
like the video please click the link
below I wrote on Twitter to the world
understand that my for developers who
usually deal with courts since the
courts been in a dormant stage for a
year are working on other projects Eric
told me that we probably need about 10
to 15 hours to upgrade the rails on
court to allow this enough to happen
against our own anyone out there a very
good rails coder that has 8 to 10 hours
for a small upgrade issue in exchange
for whatever they need at garyvee me as
soon as possible this is the power of
Twitter now right um then lots of
different people responded
lots and lots multiple pages montt lots
and lots I can help you I can help you
can I be of any help thank you so much
BP Hogan lots of different people then
send her networks mr. stern my good
friend he's a giant fan like you might
this is probably what got him going nice
amazing that Gary Vee can't just pay a
developer to help him fix the hacking
instead of he wants to exchange this is
what mr. stern thought no I love Alan so
you know I don't know why
rising here cuz he kind of knows me but
that's okay I respect that
um but I didn't like it so of course I
had to then come back in Montezuma in
put you to work at Cedric's thrilled to
pay in money Giants fan that's like the
meanest thing I thought I could say for
real to pay in money Giants fan
just wanting to offer more personal
opportunity time to look at things on
the bright side you know I was saying
don't look at it the negative maybe I'm
a positive I figured sure I'll pay but
if somebody wanted business consulting
which I charge much more for than what
this would have cost me or am I gonna
help with something
you know hug I'm good at that so you
know whatever that whatever so next what
happened
senator networks replied Alan replied
Gary be cool glad to hear hope you get
the problem Corp soon get it corked nice
little cute joke by mr. stern so I
appreciate that that made me feel better
cuz I didn't want him to look down upon
me then what happened was miss rogue mom
in here it's a beautiful picture of her
let's give her a good shout out let's
get right into their pretty picture of
her anyway
Tara Hunt who is awesome said at center
networks at Kennedy has enough Whoopi
that he can either pay in cash or Whoopi
the Whoopi is more rap roulette
relational sorry can read relational
less transactional now Tara believes in
the Whoopi factor she wrote a book about
this it's really like your social equity
right very powerful statement and what I
really believe in that's why I think
we're so cuddly and friendly you know I
believe that maybe cash isn't the
biggest thing that a coated one maybe
that can help them in other ways anyway
then what happened next month
Ryan cooter right cooter cutter right
get all riled show his face nice keep
looking dude um he said Gary Vee not
only do we have whoops
not only do we have rails guys but we
prefer Whoopie to cash your money is no
good here just fascinating how the world
is changing where people are borrowing
more for you know maybe come so I don't
know I don't maybe they're much like
football I don't I don't know but it's
amazing that you know that was kind of
where I vibe and then finally I thought
it was very interesting that I miss
Seesmic bad is what I thought Maude you
know I hadn't used the program Seesmic
the platform Seesmic in a wild villa was
a user maybe a year ago so I thought
that was kind of cool and there is
something else he been missing from here
miss Vermont let's find it for everybody
here let's go over here let's go here I
think this is quite fascinating
there is one other very fascinating part
of this whole day that I've been living
and that is my inbox and that is going
on this is thanks so Loic was very happy
and you know here's some more stuff
people keep sending me people that can
help
and so now friends you saw everything to
happen core got hacked TechCrunch wrote
about it could be a big PR nightmare I
jumped in I was honest told the truth
you know juggling too many projects
that's on the back burner though
actually it's kind of not big spring
summer thing and and then the community
responded with a lot of people saying
best response to a hack ever need a lot
of good tweets about me being genuine
you just got to be truthful you got to
stand up and take responsibility you
can't wait for your PR company to come
and run and write your post a day later
about the incident you got to take
control of your negativity just like you
come out of the Woodworks when you get
positivity and go right you have to and
what else did we learned we learned that
negative concern is positives look at
Seesmic the Seesmic founder and CEO is
thrilled that he got you know me cuz i
guess i have social media cred you know
I mean he gets a positive right he gets
talked about Tara hunt gets to talk
about her core belief and social equity
with the wolfy factor that's fascinating
I got mad at a Giants fan that's
fascinating
we learned that Twitter is a very
powerful community
come out and help as a matter of fact
last night there was a big thing that I
followed and got involved with where we
were donating for a family that was
looking for a home with three children
lots of money raised powerful tool to
build community
we also learned lots of things what else
did we learn Aman trying to think what
else we learned Seesmic school we just
learned a whole lot that a negative can
be turned into positive in my opinion I
see lots and lots of positives from here
tons and on top of that court this
watching Wine Library TV so while number
TV is getting some traffic and it's a
weird all around folks it's a win all
around negatives don't have to stay
negative be honest be truthful be very
transparent take ownership and negatives
can become positives I had a wild day
here's my question for you leave it in
the comments what was your day like